this is a production of cornell
university
i'm michael mizurik i'm a vegetable
breeder
tending to focus a lot on peppers uh
cucurbits and cookies uh and so that's
what we're gonna hear about today
uh so the title of my talk is uh the
major genes affecting vegetable quality
traits via phenopropanoid derived
metabolites
so
one of the things that i'm particularly
interested in is in chemistry
and here are some of the pictures
related to that uh
cola pete that my student james is
working on that is having some
anthocyanins there from the
fenopropanoid pathway
and then a couple other really cool
pictures i just got back from
an undergraduate student that is in
austria now that is uh sending me back
pictures of all the different flavorful
paprikas
that she's encountering and also all of
the pumpkin seed oil so this is actually
what we're going to talk about today
um and so for me uh the phenopropanoid
pathway is
been something that unifies a lot of my
interests
in vegetable quality
so a series of compounds that come from
phenylalanine are converted into the
phenyl propanoid so phenol for the
phenyl group and propane for this three
carbon group here and then they go off
to do lots of useful functions within
the plant
a lot of them are involved in disease
resistance in the work i'll talk a
little bit about today and have talked
about a lot before
capsaicin what makes hot peppers taste
hot
uh into the cell wall cell wall
fortifying compounds for lignan
production
and then also off into the colorful
antioxidant anthocyanins
and
along with that pathway i'll also talk a
little bit about another group of
compounds the proanthocyanidins
that
in many foods can have a very nice
addition to flavor but in some of the
examples i'll talk about today
actually they are the one of the major
detractors from flavor
and so this is
kind of
why i tend to focus on this pathway
and a lot of what we do about quality
is going to come from and center on the
metabolites in that pathway
a lot of what i had been doing uh the
first couple years here is focusing on
disease resistance so the two uh major
uh threats uh that we've encountered
that growers have asked us to work on is
here on pepper suffering from
phytophthora blight
and here is a cucumber leaf that's
suffering from downing mildew another
olympic pathogen and one of the the
first things i've really worked on is
finding some sources of disease
resistance to these major diseases that
we had
as breeding lights
in the program
and
starting to do some more work just
evaluating them um and so here is an
example of a pepper that is
doing fine despite all of the many many
scores of phytophthora capsici that
chris and amara have inoculated it with
so it is doing much better than
that pepper there so we have
some excellent sources of disease
resistance for phytops are in here
and for
downy mildew um well it will cause
cucumbers to typically
and quickly look like this in the field
in late summer
um
having uh some sources of resistance uh
just going through the collection seeing
what we had we were able to find that we
do have some significant sources of uh
downey mildew resistance so
um this uh
our first uh inquiry into what we had in
the program already could we have
varieties that could combat these
diseases
yes
but so then uh since these are some
major grower needs that they continue to
voice uh looking through the program
where we had you know solutions to this
we had some big questions of so why
aren't these reading lines or these
varieties used more broadly
one
big issue turned out to be definitely
grower awareness
that you know we had these resources uh
luckily i was able uh to connect with uh
chris smart from geneva early on on the
work here and got some varieties up to
the phytophthora farm in geneva
they
turned out to be quite resistant we had
some really promising material
and so then
the next step and something that you
know chris helped me uh orchestrate is
really just connecting with all of
the great
extension personnel around the state and
right now i'm happy to say that a lot of
our seed from those resistant peppers
as a result of the collaboration with
chris and now working with
the much larger group of folks is
actually getting out onto grover's
fields uh they're starting to sow the
seeds this week
so one big
hurdle has overcome there so now we have
these resistant varieties that
growers are trying to learn more about
the other question though with that why
they might not be using these varieties
is a question of yield
so
here is one of the results from our tour
sustainability project from
last summer where we're looking at yield
of cucumber plants planted in the late
season planting out in the field on the
organic flats and freedom we're looking
at the weeks after transplant along this
axis and
the cumulative weight we harvested off
the plots on that axis
and what we saw was that although we had
some plants that quickly just almost
spontaneously combusted in the field
that would be totally decimated by
disease and some of our resistant lines
had kept trucking along and
still looked quite disease resistant
it was actually some of these highly
susceptible lines that had the most
yield uh so uh two popular lines here
dasher two of the triangle uh and
quintolino the variety as you pictured
here in the open squares they were
highly productive despite being highly
susceptible to disease
a lot of our
resistant cultivars down here so for
instance market more 97 which is
commercially available and turns out to
be highly resistant to downy mildew it
just really doesn't quite have the yield
to compete with the other ones and
it was a grower you sell cucumbers not
cucumber foliage
so
you know there's a big need to from the
growers perspective you know they want
resistant varieties but they also need
to have the yield um so in this case
it's not a lost cause after looking at
uh doing the formal comparison last
summer
the the clear difference between this
group and this group is whether or not
the crop is uh ganesha's so having an
all-female crop
you can see if we take market more 97
and just simply insert
the genetics for all female flowering we
should be able to quickly get up to this
level of yield if not higher
so
looking at what we had we know for some
of these yield is a problem but
and that's the reason why growers would
be using it but we know how to overcome
that so that's uh probably also not
going to be an issue
um
so the the third reason uh something
that we are looking at are varieties to
actually make them a complete package
something that the growers will really
uh want to use is comes down to a matter
of quality and that's
what i came to talk today about and it's
a good time because now that we're
starting to really refocus on
quality in our in my program and the the
chemistry behind that
so it has been a hypothesis in the
literature for a while
it really
became popular uh when harry klee was
proposing it a couple years ago where he
was doing surveys of all the aromatic
volatiles in the vegetable everything
that we think smells really good about a
fruit and finding that
those aroma volatiles we like tend to be
derived from byproducts of essential
nutrients produced in the plant
and
other people have also talked about the
same phenomena and just the notion that
a lot of the sensory cues we get from a
plant
is really cueing us into its nutritional
values so all of the colors and aromas
we might get from different fruits and
vegetables
are really what's cueing us in as to
these are really helpful and good
uh and the story that harry was talking
about and this kind of a lot of people
are familiar with now is taking a look
at either the
grocery store tomato that's become a bit
of a cliche now for being pink and
crunchy and flavorless and then some of
the more much more flavorful much more
pigmented lush
cultivars it can be a paint
or even some of the novel niche
categories as people are starting to
more and more
want to try to paint vegetables purple
it's a common theme and a lot of plant
breeding now is to have a purple crop so
you know again the idea is with the
anthocyanins is an extra health benefit
uh and so even in asparagus uh there's
the purple asparagus available um
one thing uh here because
kind of against the hypothesis is
our white asparagus here it doesn't have
the the visual cues but in terms of its
aroma
it actually has more of some of the
central amino acids than the others so
it's always a balance between
what can we produce that really fits in
the mainstream
views of quality what a consumer wants
and quality and how much room is there
for these niche vegetables that also are
high quality but look a little bit
different than some people expect
but there's been like you mentioned with
painting some of the crops purple
there's been some great success uh just
a few days ago i was talking with uh
frank morton uh a uh a
lettuce breeder
who is
readily able to uh do his own plant
breeding and selection on farm for
different salad green mixes that have an
array of different anti-sign in profiles
and along with that comes some very
different interesting flavors
and
over
in england uh there are some amateur
plant breeders that are
actually reintroducing us to some uh pea
varieties that haven't been seen in a
long time in some cases uh recreating
them and so here is a
a woman that has a website to showcase
her pee
reading talents where she is trying to
recreate a red potted snap peak
so
the problem with working with some of
the anthocyanins uh is that it's not as
simple as
painting uh the fruit uh different color
or the pot a different color
so
this is a quote actually i got from
a geneva student uh gary tariq's thesis
uh from the 80s uh and we're just kind
of rediscovering uh some of this work
now
um
that although you can get these
pretty colors and the flowers and then
along with that you tend to also get
anthocyanins and seeds and you can also
have other transcription factors that
will further turn on the anthocyanins
and pods
having this anthocyanin up regulation is
unfortunately associated with really
poor quality
for some of the the processors that
would be because when you uh go to
canned purple peas you end up with a can
of
gray dingy grape
in terms of the the pod
is actually
you get some flavor profiles that really
aren't
what you're after
and to jump back to there's no slide but
what the
the source of that is is that when you
turn on the anthocyanin pathway to
have all these flavonoid colors in the
feed
you also end up
also up regulating the proanthocyanidin
pathway condensed cannons which might be
really nice in a cup of coffee or a dark
red wine
but are not necessarily the flavor
profile you want to go for with a sweet
sugar snap pea it's kind of conflicting
so
we wanted to start to do some work
to genetically dissect
what
was possible in peak can we separate the
two
some some things were already known but
we
started to go after that with a new set
of tools
so we started out
this is some work from my student james
keach where we start to get a collection
of different pea flowers so a typical
garden white flower pea
the yellowish orange flower peace and
full of them a different species also
some pink flowered on some
purple flower peas and here's just uh
hydrochloric acid and methanol extract
of the different flower parts
and i should also mention that and
starting to look at some of the
connections between color and the
triangle cyanogens it's also something
that's of interest to the forage folks
and so to
kind of broaden the study
started a collaboration with the other
new hire in the department royce murphy
and we have uh and so we're starting to
look at some of his uh alfalfa flower
colors where he has challenged me that
any fl flower color i can find in a p
he has the same thing and better in
alfalfa and so we're starting to
integrate uh some of his breathing lines
into the analysis also
but anyway so just to look at a couple
of these now or actually let's look at
the chemistry of it off
so if you start to do the analysis one
thing we can take advantage of is
there's really only six major
anthocyanins uh in nature there's some
other forms but they're really quite
rare and some more obscure species but
we have these six
uh major forms
that are just very on their whether
they're hydroxylated at some of these r
group positions around the ring
but they can be very very
uh extensively diverse based on what
sugar moiety they have isolated to these
two positions
but since they all have some of the same
core structure
we're able to take advantage of that in
the analysis
and so here is a lot of chromatography
that was done across the street by
reichel colishi
and so what we did were two
reminders we have the different uh pea
flowers uh that we've had the methanol
extract and
uh ryco ran it through
an hplc where on the top graph we have a
chromatogram of the photodiode array so
looking at the light absorbance
and having all the different colored
molecules show up here
and then within that what you do is you
cue in on all of the different core
anthocyanin base molecules so without
all the sugars added
and so by having uh selected masses to
pull out of here he could then go for
instance say that he knows the 287 mass
corresponds to cyanidines the 301 mass
corresponds to pyongyang
and could pull out what are all the
different core uh a-glycone structures
of the anthocyanins
then
the nice feature of the particular type
of mass spectrometer he has
is then once they've pulled out those
masses and can line those masses up with
a peak they can go back and do what they
call a precursor ion scan and so
basically asks so what are all the
molecules that when they broke down
resulted in having the pioneering core
group and so then we can start to look
at all of the different sugar mighties
so while we can just focus on the six
major uh anthocyanin egg glycones
reicho is now looking at at least 39
different
anthocyanin groups that he is finding
so here is a pink pea
flower showing the cyanidine and
pyonetin
and then here is the same experiment for
this purple flower where you can see the
mix of delphinidin patunitin and melvin
and so
this is not anything that wasn't
necessarily known before about the pea
flowers
but we're just able to start to look at
it with a lot more detail and accuracy
and to start to really explore and find
actually new compounds that weren't
recorded before
and then you know the end goal will be
to within the same spectrum to try to be
able to capture all the flavonols the
quercetins that are the important health
compounds and also some of the
cyanidines which are the bittering
compounds in the piece
and this is uh of course it's
very interesting for us to see what are
all the different uh the anthocyanin
anthocyanin compounds and the peas and
study a little bit more about the
molecular genetics behind it
but also as part of a larger breeding
project in collaboration with jim myers
is to start to develop some more
stringless sugar snap peas for the area
and
for me
to start to get some that have some of
the purple coloration
and so again here we're after the full
package of having
a purple string with snap peak so for
stringlessness that is a single
recessive gene to remove the string
in the grocery store most of the peas
you'll see now you'll notice they are
missing the stem because they are
starting to become more and more counter
the stringless snap peas because they're
more readily machine harvested to hold
then for the snap tea it's actually a
combination of three different recessive
genes two recessive genes that can
combine to remove this inner parchment
layer
and then a third that's involved in
making the pods fall to make the snap
pee so here would be the snow pea and
then there would be the snap
with the problem working with some of
the the streamless material is by virtue
of being streamless we're starting to
affect the phenoproline pathway we're
reducing the plant's ability to produce
some kind of propanoid related defense
compounds some of the sclerenchyma
tissues that uh are being removed also
in the process especially with the
massively gliotropic streamless allele
having lots of other phenopropanoids
change within the plant
and so
we have a struggle now to try to figure
out how to balance a lot of different
traits
and so again one of the issues has been
how can we produce anthocyanins without
producing the proanthocyanids
so there are some genes that have been
reported that can actually decouple
those and so that is something
we're looking at now um
recently it's become available uh
actually a purple snap pea that is
claimed uh to
not have some of those bitter off
flavors so it's touted as the the first
good tasting purple peanut
and so we're
we're got some of that we haven't i
haven't tried it yet we're planning it
out for the first time this year but
looking at
the seed coat of the peas so this is the
seed coat of a typical purple potted pea
and you can see some of this anthocyanin
speckling on it
whereas here we have
a pea from the new variety sugar
magnolia a great name for a purple teeth
and it's lacking the purple speckling
kind of universally
one of the genes that is known
to
be able to remove some of the
proanthocyanidins
um
would also cause this effect
so for us it's going to be also
interesting as we start to look at
these genetics and some of the other
genetics that are available to decouple
these is with the strenuous mutation as
we are stopping the the leading
production and affecting the rest of the
pencil propanoid pathway
uh you start to lose that cold soil
germination
the early
young seedling disease resistance
whereas once you add the dominant aging
you turn on anthocyanin biosynthesis
actually
the seed coat becomes much more disease
resistant and so it's going to be a
question of trying to figure out how the
stringless genes
interact with the anthocyanin genes
to see
how they are not only affecting quality
and plant vigor but also potentially
that early seedling disease resistance
so
right now
that is a work in progress we'll be
looking at some of the peas again this
summer and continuing to look at some of
the anthocyanins
the other project this one is again
focusing uh largely on some of the
malignant and hemis cellulose
biosynthetic pathways uh starting to
look at squash seed oil so up in geneva
uh that greg woodward that the stony
brook whole hearted foods
has started up a very great business
pressing
seeds that are left over from
the squash processing into a really
nutritious flavorful oil
and so greg is taking advantage of
something that's known
in austria
and has been known for quite a while is
in austria the pumpkin seed oil is a
very desirable flavor
here's
an image leave us in the bag of some
pumpkin seed oil flavored chips
this lady here is not bemoaning the
grass stain on her skirt but rather just
being i guess as part of the pumpkin
seed oil ad being excited that you know
she is
part of austrian culture by getting some
of the pumpkin seed spilled on her this
is the actual advertising for the
oilseed company is that it stains
it does stay quite a bit you can see so
here are some of those mutant
seeds
that are used for the oil seed
production
because they're very
high yielding because they lack seat
coats uh and a result of liking the seed
coats so the inner layers are
more upregulated and so you have a
really dark green layer
surrounding the seed and that is what
gets
the stains on to close
so
we started to do some work into the
genetics of this trait as well it ties
in with understanding how the
phenylprotanoid pathway is affecting
some of the quality
so here on the far side of the slide is
an example of some different uh hollis
uh seeds that are available uh so down
here on the bottom are some of the
commercial oil seed
pumpkin seeds and up here are some
others that are i don't think is used
widely in production
but i still have the hulless trait so
here would be like a kakai and here
would be a lady godiva
so that's something naked uh of squash
these are the hardest ones and here
again in the cross section you can see
where there's really no seed coat
some of these have a little bit along
the edge of kind of a ligno cellulose
strip
but you can really see the difference as
you start to look in
this column and how radically the seed
coat thickness can change uh as we go
from a virtually hollis seed to a thin
hull that's found on like cucurbita pipo
seeds so here's the summer squash seed
here is a cucurbita moshata seed which
is starting to get more
more of a seed coat and
tending to be quite rough and then here
in the usually beautifully wood grain
looking cucurbit and maximus seeds the
seed is quite thick
and so what we wanted to start to do is
to look at
the seed coat a little bit more detail
as we're going to try to study the gene
in more detail as a project my student
lindsay is working on
is to try to figure out you know what
more should we know about the seed coat
and so a great opportunity
we found across the street
um
so over uh
in wild hall they have a ct scanner with
some quite good resolution and so what
we started to do is try to see can this
help us with phenotyping the seed or at
least help us to see things we were
missing before in the sea
so here's a 25 micron resolution scan of
the cucurbita maxima seed that in the
slide before you can see has this really
thick
seed coat here and we can actually go in
and measure it at different points along
the seed coat you see you know different
in this slice it's ranging from 782 to
567
microns and compare that to a cute
curvature people see
which it's you know much thinner so we
can actually start to really get some
nice measurements of it
then beyond just getting it one static
slice through the image
one thing that we've been able to do is
start to look at this in three
dimensions uh and so for the folks in
geneva i should point out that i'm going
to hit play on the 3dc movie now
but to start to do some of the 3d
rendering capacities of the ct scanner
so here is that success pm the cucurbita
people summer squash seed
and by playing with the ability of the
x-ray to see different densities we can
dissolve away the seed coat get a good
look at the embryo
where the cotyledons are the major
oil storage tissue
and look at it in various dimensions and
also then be able to
go through the seat and be able to
measure basically at any
depth
angle we want and see how the embryo is
actually filling it as compared to where
we see the seam code
and then back to the slides
and so as we're starting to look at the
seeds in more detail
one of the reasons that's going to be
important is there can be degrees of the
seed coat present and so one thing we
want to do in being able to not only get
a good handle on what are
you know the different different
qualitative traits there's one
qualitative gene that's modifying uh
whether or not we have the seed coat but
there's also some quantitative traits
that can cause different degrees of the
seed coat to appear and to get a truly
naked seeded hollis
cultivar we really have to do a better
job of understanding what all these
modifiers are so we can use a
marker-assisted breeding strategy
so part of what we're doing
is just crossing also this
uh naked seeded hulless trait into a
delicata squash and you can see there's
varying degrees of delicateness emerging
from some of those breeding lines and
also introducing into an acorn squash
and here
the goal is to have a squash that um
with the the processing squash they have
a very nice system now so after they
make the in the grocery store you have
the cubed peeled ready to cook squash
that's done in a plant they can if they
want to press the oil for seed they have
the facilities in the setup to do it
but for the person at home
if you just get an acorn squash and cut
it open
the seeds are very healthful very
nutritious
i think they taste great
it's a question of you know could we
make it so when you open up the squash
you get those same you know naked seeded
oil seed high nutrient seeds
other things we're doing also is
i know every time
we grow zucchinis we always end up with
a couple huge lunkers left over at the
end of the season
let's go straight to the compost bin
this is also a treat we're inserting
into zucchini
so that all those leftover squashes at
the end of the year we can have a nice
nutritious second crop essentially
and one of the uh
tools we had hoped to use uh in this
process was a number of uh linked ssr
markers there's tightly linked uh to the
major hullis trait
in squash and so here we started to try
to use a marker assisted
back cross strategy to be able to insert
the
hollis
trait into zucchini
and we got
some excellent results at first
and it turned out to be a really good
thing that we kept all the plants and
they just throw them away
it turns out that's the ssr markers that
we had started using
turned out not to be linked to the trait
so
i figured this would be my one chance to
show
all the great molecular marker work
we did very intrepidly but turned out to
be um
it's a very clear indication there needs
to be some work done and actually
getting uh some new markers up for the
train and to try to
you know definitely lots of room to
actually now start moving towards a
better molecular understanding of the
nature of the gene behind the trait
and also besides this being a
potentially interesting new cultivars
all of these different breeding lines
have our different integration lines
also be very important for trying to
study the trait
and i think lindsay will be telling you
more about how the project's going in
the coming years
so the the last video i wanted to tell
is about
hot peppers and capsaicinoids uh some of
you have probably heard a lot parts of
the story before
but i really like the story so i hope
you do um
so uh one of my interests early on was
in habanero pepper flavored this hot
pepper flavor and how
you know the hot peppers seem to have
flavors that just a regular pepper
doesn't uh started to work with
some spice companies that were also very
interested in having pepper flavor uh
how can you have pepper flavor without
burning out your customers and once
mcdonald's is starting to feature
chipotle flavor you know roasted red
jalapeno flavor is one of
their major menu ingredients i know
there's a big interest in the flavor but
how can you separate flavor from heat
because hot pepper flavor you'd always
seem to have hot pepper flavor and hot
pepper different approaches have been
tried
so this is
a non-hot jalapeno called full view
sometimes you get one that
has outcrossed and then
it's a whole different joke down the
consumer
and then you know the habanero is you
know the hottest or was the hottest uh
hot pepper uh and there's also for the
people that are interested enough to try
it the source of some really interesting
wonderful flavors
um
and so what we wanted to start to try to
do is develop a pepper
that you know didn't have
the heat this other flavor and what we
ended up with is this pepper that uh i
always
show this picture a lot
but this is a
a good example of being able to
get out and really talk to growers and
producers and consumers and retailers uh
originally we were going after trying to
make a habanero pepper that was
something that really looked like a
habanero
without the heat and what we heard back
was that no retailer would dare ever
sell it because the regular habanero
could hop in to not hop in and if you
couldn't tell them apart uh that would
end in lawsuits so what we ended up
doing is going back a few generations
where it had these different elongated
peppers and actually this worked out
well because they had a lot more aroma
on flavor and the yield was just
incredible
so we started to do a breeding project
for this habanero without heat and then
later on developed the tools to start to
actually look at and what was going on
in more detail
so a lot of this
makes use of some technology i think
it's also an outfit geneva in the
viticulture analogy program
but
instead of a regular gas chromatograph
what this one is doing is it has a
polymer fiber that's able to sample all
the aroma volatiles that are coming off
the sample it runs a standard uh gc
master chromatograph run uh but in
addition to just the mass spec detector
the other detector is you uh and so it's
a matter of sniffing along uh as the
machine is measuring all the different
compounds that come out and as you have
a different sensory reaction oh this
smells grassy this smells caddy or
smells fruity
you can take those time points and those
percepts and match them up with the ms
results
and so we were able to get some hits uh
where we could line up a chemical like
beta ionome with a percept but in
general uh there's a disagreement
between uh how abundant a compound was
that we could feel the mass spectrometer
and whether or not we actually work
smelling or sensing it
so for instance a lot of these esters
are quite abundant but they're really
not abundant enough
to be able to smell them
in the gco
probably mostly because because of the
threshold of the compounds
but the the most interesting result of
this was the finding that
all these aroma volatiles and everything
that smell good about a habanero pepper
was coming from the same part of the
pepper that's really hot and spicy so on
the inside of a habanero pepper
especially these
white ribs and bell peppers what you
would throw out while you're cooking it
this is covered with these yellow
glandular blisters where the capsaicin
comes oozing out in great quantities
and in that same oil you find all the
aroma follicles and so here it shows
the gcms profile
of a whole uh habanero pepper and here
it's m council millions of pounds and
every other tissue of the pepper was
really didn't have any of the aroma
volatiles by the mass spectrometer or
to smell them
so here's the thousands of pounds i've
just seen the baseline here
but if we were to just cut out this
placenta decephament the white ribs here
and put them in
the machine then we get back up to
millions of pounds and a similar profile
before and all the aroma we can even
take a q-tip swab and just wipe up some
of the oil
and then that of course
was a very spicy q-tip
but also that had lots of all the aroma
volatiles back so the aroma volatiles
are coming from the same
tissue as you know the spice
and so it's been a question of them
okay so
how can we get
hot pepper flavor without the heat can
we do it naturally in a pepper
and with uh you know that one habanada
pepper uh the habanero without the heat
we had mostly done that and so it was a
question of
so
how does that work
um
and so it was actually just a matter of
using some uh different alleles uh that
were different mutations uh that result
in the lack of heat like you'd find in a
bell pepper some different alleles from
different species can decouple the heat
production from the aroma production
so
our collaborator in new mexico mary
o'connell had been doing some
very nice sem micrographs to start to
look at the blisters and these oil
filled blisters you can see the bumps
here
on this tissue
and then comparing that to the much
smoother unblistered skin you find in
pepper that's not hot so it's lacking
these capsaicinoid blisters
so with
the the discovery of the ct scanner next
door
we of course ran right over with some
habaneros and
mark was game so in geneva i'm going to
play the the pepper movie now
and
this is just one of my my favorite runs
we've done
and so here is again the 3d uh rendering
from the ct scanner uh letting us
actually start to look inside the
peppers and one of the the great things
and i just love these photos because you
can see all of the blisters all along
this the inside of the pepper
and actually start to count and account
for area
and
when we started to you know do some of
these skins one of the reasons we're
doing them is just because
it was fun you know
let us see
some different perspectives on uh what
the what we were working on in the lab
and
definitely you know it's as i you know
talk about some different plant tissues
and class of it definitely helps to help
me engage as an instructor better uh
but it just for us it's been remarkable
and you can see the detail in here just
being able to see all the different
blisters
and
what actually after looking at some of
these
we started to make some observations
that we need to now
follow up that's been just really
exciting is the this is a habanero
pepper it used to be the hottest pepper
in the world
it's not the hottest pepper in the world
any longer there's this new pepper the
boot jolokia or the nagajolokia so these
new super hot peppers that are three
times hotter than a habanero
and so one of our questions has been is
geneticist is oh can we break it down so
what are the genetics that allow it to
be so hot
one of the tricks we already know uh i
think we know
is that
they measure heat in the pungency or the
amount of these capsaicinoid alkaloid
compounds per gram of pepper
so you don't necessarily have to produce
more capsaicin you have to produce more
heat compounds you can just produce less
grams of pepper
and looking at the peppers
one of the interesting things you find
is so here are these placental ribs
which are naturally very light and very
pithy after doing
lots of rna extractions from lots of hub
and arrows you start to notice things
so one of the things we notice after
dissecting several hundred habaneros
it's something to become ingrained in
you is this tissue is very light pithy
fluffy um
those jolokia peppers that are much
hotter than a habanero are also their
whole pericarp instead of being a heavy
fleshy pericarp is also lightning pithy
like the placenta so one of the next
things i'm going to do is
grow some more boujoloqias and take them
over to
mark because it'll be very interesting
to be able to
get some skins of those and really to
compare the densities and that might be
the way we start to quantify some of the
phenotypes at least in some of the
parents to see you know is this really
what we're seeing
um and so again uh in uh the
the mild habanero uh the the secret has
really been starting to take advantage
of some of these other alleles that have
other mutations instead of the major
deletion you find in a bell pepper there
is just a simple indel frame shift
mutation in the chinense background that
we've been breeding with
and
the original experiment we did was just
across a pepper that had this mutation
so it wasn't hot it didn't have any
aroma with a habanero
that had all these aroma feeds
and then in the f2 population a nice
simple relationship showed up where we
have a straightforward relationship
where we have two groups of peppers so
we can do a principal component analysis
of the aroma
what basically it's separating out is
the presence of these big ester peaks
here
but we have a group that contains a lot
of the aroma the wild type volatile
profile capsaicinoids and is wild type
15.
and so
we have the one gene and that's what's
controlling whether the pepper is hot
and that's controlling whether or not
these aroma volatiles are produced so
it's basically just one big switch
turning both pathways off and on
but we are able to get some peppers that
start to have this aroma back
and so here this is the old way of
looking at the capsaicin blisters we
have these large yellow blisters on a
wild type plant
we have the lack of those blisters on
the mutant habaneros and on the leaky
alleles it literally is leaky
and that some of the mutant plants we
get a little blister with a little bit
of that spicy oil coming out and also
quite a bit of the aroma coming out
and so this was
really exciting to us to start to
explain actually kind of what's going on
in the pepper's metabolism and basically
we know now we can kind of turn off and
on heat and aroma and know they're
coupled
another
opportunity that's come up those now is
that we know more of this
there are also other peppers that are
hot but lack aroma or have the aroma and
now we're trying to move towards some of
those populations
where we have the heat fixed but aroma
is segregated
and
they can see just the really intimate
relationship of
the aroma is an encapsulation noise once
you go back to
uh the biosynthetic pathway and look
again we're gonna get back to the fennel
propanoids again um
where you have a typical
pathway that's found in a lot of fruits
to produce aromatic
aroma volatiles where you have
an alcohol added to
an acid to make an ester and then it's
just a matter of in the capsaicinoid
molecules that's going to make the
pepper spicy it's many of the same
precursors
for the fatty acids can be made into the
carboxyl tails that are formed the tail
of the capsaicinoids and so we have two
metabolic pathways that are sharing some
of the same precursors
and actually it does look like they're
competing for some of the precursors
because the most common uh
branched groups that are incorporated
into the tails of the capsaicinoids are
the least common that's available in the
same glandular areas for the aroma
volatiles
um so those were the the three stories i
wanted to share about uh some of the
different quality aspects we're looking
at and how it all kind of centers on the
fennel propanoid pathway and it gets
work that we are just gearing up
on but i wanted to share
kind of what where we're at now and i
think the directions you can see for the
future
and i want to thank a lot of people that
contributed to this uh chris smart amara
gun and lots of people from
extension uh we're working on some of
the phytophthora disease resistance uh
the high tunnel work on collaboration
with chris wein and a lot of help from
leah jessica eliza and michael
a lot of the phytophthora breeding
for the peppers was originally done by
matt felice here
the anthocyanin work i showed
was done by james keach
reicho
and jim myers is helping us with a lot
of the breeding work on the stringless
snaps
the seed work uh was uh done by
lindsay and nancy iannetta the images uh
mark over across the road um
nancy ianetta did a lot of the work on
getting some of the markers up and
running in some of the new fluorescent
ssrs and david bolier and kelsek
was instrumental in getting a lot of the
enrollment analysis done and thank you
for the opportunity to come here and
share this with you today
yes chris
michael i was wondering
as you take the husk off the
squash or pumpkins
what happens to the german ability and
its resistance to soil-borne organisms
in germination and cold soil
it's it becomes an issue
you know it's kind of
the counter part for the piece story
that way where in p we're interested in
how can we get a more durable seam code
that's more resistant and here is just
by virtue of what we're doing we're
trying to remove that
the
main
issue we tend to have is actually by
vipring of the seeds uh if we don't get
them out of the fruit in time
they do tend to germinate so it's been a
learning experience of how to deal with
that and talk to some growers and seed
producers that actually you know they do
this quite well and
in austria it's one of the national
crops so i think they have it down well
it's been a matter of learning some of
their tricks
i've done some work with apples where
we're looking at polyphenolics
which is
very much a genotype thing but there's a
big environmental
difference too we look at one genotype
over three or four years
sometimes we'll see an order of
magnitude difference between one growing
season and another
do you see that with the hot peppers as
well or is it more
or less consistent yeah and i think it's
in uh the peas where we can in the
flavor that's where the bitterness will
come and go it'll be a similar thing
with the hot peppers it's definitely an
environmentally responsive pathway
you know it's also a matter of rain
if you have a hot dry summer
you'll have some hot peppers i'm really
uh also interested we've never really
there tends to be lots of inherent
variability even between fruit and a
single pepper plant so how hot they are
it's always been a difficult experiment
to do
but a lot of the the type of work andre
kessler does looking at how you can have
a plant uh cube uh to another plant is
the work they do with uh method jasmine
inducing uh the alkaloids in tobacco
plants it could also probably have a lot
of relevance in the hot pepper
so
one thing i've always wondered about
that is it a question of genes that are
turned on and off on environmental cues
or is it a question of
substrate limitation or more
quantitative differences between one
season and another
there's been
there's been there's been a lot of
studies on that but they all seem to
have
differing results it's been a matter of
again even within the pepper plant
there's so much variability so how can
you get a very accurate measurement uh
and also
people have tended to do different
studies with their own favorite
type of pepper and so there could be
just
i think there are some peppers that are
much more environmentally responsive
than others so they naturally just have
larger era bars than others
but i think it's
no one knows i think it's
because it's been really hard to
actually quantify how a pepper isn't
even for a lot of the hot pepper
industry
getting a pepper that's consistently hot
is a big problem often what they'll do
is have the
the not hot blend and then just add some
hot to it so they can actually calibrate
the amount of heat by adding it rather
than trying to just achieve it through
the harvest
do you know what the dark colors are
actually like what pigments they're
attributed
yeah um so it is the
the pre chlorophyll what's the
protocol um and then also
lutein
is quite abundant
so if you make oils out of it doesn't it
cause oxidation when you have abundance
of chlorophyll enough
because i know that in canola industry
when you're working with canola oil
right they want to separate out all the
green seeds so that it doesn't cause
oxidation in the oil
so if it has such high abundance that it
stains white cloves
would it have
like an oxidation effect
well
is it also a matter of the
so there with the the green seeds is it
a matter of maturity or well they use it
they use they know that uh chlorophyll
uh presence and seed is attributed to
maturity like a less mature seed has
more chlorophyll and a mature seed has
less of that chlorophyll
so you can use that as a maturity
in that
but i think in their case it's more
about
when the weather is cold
the seeds don't mature fully by the time
they harvest so that's why they have
green seeds
yeah so and then that can cause the
green color pigments
leaching into the oil which then causes
for like quality damage
yeah so i think the the difference might
be that these seeds are fully mature i
know with some of the
other oil seed crops there's a big
interest in uh black versus the yellow
seeded breast cannabis and so there it's
an issue of uh
with the black seed you have a stained
oil and you get less oil yield
so here it's i think it's
it's
definite i don't think there are many
issues with the stability of it it
tends to be a cold pressed oil
and so i think there are
you know to retain the maximum health
benefits usually you use it before too
long
but i don't think there's any major
oxidation issues with it i don't know i
don't know why
that's a good question
50 some years ago
i did my phd thesis on a gene and peace
and
i was interested in tasting the
bitterness in the seat coats
and
my advisor bill kelly was able to taste
it very readily
but most people could not taste it have
you
you've talked about the genetic
variability as far as the crop is
concerned or seasoned
what about people do you find
differences there
so far i was very proud uh to show lots
of people uh my purple piece and kind of
universally they said oh this is really
nice but it tastes a little off michael
um
so i think so far and so there we're
looking at
uh
stamp keys or snow peas so we're
actually
going to the pod and the seeds are small
and only partially developed
so i i haven't done much uh look at
the seed coat to actually taste the
seeds as much as we tend to be more
interested in the pod but
we will probably be finding that out
but i think it's
no it's it's a flavor that it's not
in a vegetable flavor it's just not
something you would
normally
expect to find in a really sweet
succulent
snap key kelly would tell me that in the
seat coat of the bee
it was stranger
yeah
um
that's
you know definitely what everything says
um as uh
and there's a
single gene uh collins that would then
remove
that um
and so it's uh
it hasn't been studied much uh in a very
in quite a while to my knowledge but i
think that
i found that there was a gene mp and
another one in k
and
i don't know if you know lamprey
uh there's a swedish speaker who had uh
i had a lot of his flying 578. it had
five recessive genes so even though a
was dominant there was no
it was free from uh
not only any anthocyanin but not any of
the what we call the membrane
right yeah
yeah no there's definitely uh
p is
even though i i love genetics p is one
of the areas where i definitely feel a
little intimidated uh because
some of the the genotypes for some of
the lines we're working with will
go across the screen a couple times
there's a lot in there and i think it's
still the
key and the fun is looking at all the
epistatic interactions between them and
the the aging was just recently cloned
and elucidated so they now know the
transcription factor uh that causes the
anthocyanin up regulation i think
there's going to be a lot of potential
in the near future to then find all the
other transcription factors that can
turn on anthocyanins and all the other
parts of the plant
another two transcription factors uh
further to go from just having a purple
flower to a purple pot
the other thing have you tried the bee
gene with your snap bees
there's rose colored flowers there's
cyanidine in the flower i think in the
flower but certainly in the seed coat
it's uh yeah instead of defending them
with what that thing is
and so uh and that's uh actually what uh
is in this slide here is
uh i thought i had the great idea of
reading these old these papers uh where
they had these red potted peas i was
like well this would be fantastic and
then a little bit later i find on the
internet
this woman that's doing it in her
backyard
quite well yeah so yeah it's uh so that
is a gene that i think
especially that's interesting to me
because uh uh my my neighbor in uh in
bradfield was walter dion and so he was
it's uh really similar to what goes on
in
potatoes
so it's probably the same gene it's just
a matter of
calling it and trying to study it
the one of the
big interesting things for us has been
how you have different diversities of
anthocyanins in different
tissue types so you have that
transcription factor to turn on the
presence of anthocyanins but you don't
always get the same anthocyanins all
throughout the feed
so it'll be another interesting thing to
learn more about
but you have things to share i'd love to
find out more i'd like to talk to you
great
should ask if there's any uh any
questions from geneva
okay
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu